this is a production of Cornell
University
hello everyone my name is Khalil Ogawa
and I'm happy to share with you my
research on cassava touch preferences of
smaller farmers in Uganda in this
picture the farmer was telling me that
he was impressed by the use of this
cassava plant cassava is an important
source of food and it is estimated that
over 500 million people eat cassava on a
daily basis and in Uganda where I come
from cassava is our second most
important staple food crop all the parts
of the cassava plant are usually in one
way or another but for food we normally
use the cassava roots over the recent
past a lot of efforts have been focused
on improving cassava for agronomic
traits our butter has been less emphasis
put on researching on improving quality
preferences most especially those of
women who do a lot of work regarding
cassava production and processing and
hence this consequently our limits the
adoption and usage of improved cassava
varieties hence there is need to link
FAMAS knowledge to that of the breeders
and my work will be trying to address to
contribute to $1 wings they are
knowledge gap in three different ways
the first one will be to identify the
traits differences of smaller farmers
then second they will be to optimize the
phenotypes phenotyping protocols for the
identified trees and the studies to
understand the genetic basis of the
preferred trait
our first study was aimed at
identification as cassava traits
differences of smaller farmers we
conducted this study in four districts
in Uganda and
we had a number of factors that we'll
consider to select the four districts
which included were interested in areas
with high cassava production high
diversity of land races and low disease
pressure so within each district we
randomly selected 128 farmers stratified
by age and sex to participate in the
study and we collected the data by
holding focus group discussions with
small groups of farmers and
administering some structured interviews
to individual farmers in total we had we
had started to focus group discussions
and administered 192 interviews we also
collected cassava leaf samples from all
the farmers fields our window cover with
on the older pummels with inversion to
the cassava varieties that they were
growing and this will help us to
understand the genetic diversity of the
familes
cultivars during the data collection the
farmers responses were handwritten and
but as a measure for quality control we
also did audio recordings so one the
first steps we did in processing the
data was to convert the handwritten
notes to the digital format and do the
transcription of the audio recording
store documents and lesser translate the
word documents from the three-row core
language is to English then we did the
data analysis using SPSS which is the
software that is commonly used for
analyzing social science data one of the
questions we ask the farmers was to tell
us the different legs above the cassava
varieties that they were blowing
and in this graph I'm showing the top
the top nine traits that the summation
on x-axis the Tres with the stars are
what some are mentioned but they are
currently not being addressed in the
breeding program so much as the family
are interested in high-yielding
customers with edema chirring they also
mentioned that they wanted customer
groups that castle varieties who do get
soft on boiling and whose roots can show
a longer in ground
we also asked the farmers to tell us the
different ways in which they eat cassava
and in inhale the boiled form of had the
highest proportion fold by the front and
the lives were had the smallest
proportion so the other question we
asked was to tell us about the different
attributes of cassava that we are
desirable for for it to be eaten in each
of these phones and in this graph I'm
showing the subservient traits that they
mentioned that were priority for the
cassava to be eaten in the boiled form
as in the previous bar graph the trips
with the stars are what the farmers
mention but are currently not being
addressed in the breeding program and
for my next to my next two studies have
decided to focus on softness of the
cassava roots because currently it was
mentioned as the number one trick for
cassava to bitten the world foam but
currently it's not being addressed in
the breeding program so the next study
will be aimed at optimizing the
protocols we can use to measure softness
we established the trail to use for this
today in 2015 as to face in Uganda using
augmented block design and the genotypes
that we used we're 210 accession that
will collected from the farmers who
participated in the survey along with 70
vendors who will vote from the breeding
program in Uganda then we have vested
arm this trial last year in October and
Travis who collected the cassava loot
samples which are being analyzed before
biochemical properties that might relate
to softness so when we go to the
laboratory with boiled the equal
sections of the cassava root at a
constant temperature and we measured
softness using the electrometer and this
is the picture for the parameter for
those who are not familiar we we are
also analyzing the samples for different
biochemical properties that may that may
correlate to the quality preferences and
this could be there is a leading this
because if they are more highly
heritable and higher created to the
quality preferences that we identified W
- Code Blue in direct reading for those
traits in this prod in this program I am
showing the phenotypic variations for
the results we got for softness using
the combined data set from the two sides
and on the y axis this is the force this
is on the y axis is the force that was
used to penetrate through the loops
after we boiled them
and on the x-axis the different time
intervals at which we measured the
softness and one thing to say as we
increase the same of boiling dub you the
first you used to penetrate through the
loops goes on decreasing and this is
because as we boiled the roots they get
softer we also consider the blood
Sensibility
using Joomla Roland's method and once
observed is the serviceability estimate
increases also increase the time of
waiting but as we move from 45 minutes
to 60 minutes the health ability
estimate becomes law and this is because
of at sixty minutes most of the loop
samples have overcooked and it becomes
hard to precisely measure softness so
the analysis is still ongoing and once
we complete rest will render the
correlations between the basecoat
biochemical properties and the quality
preferences and for the biochemical
properties that are highly related to
softness we will establish the scoring
skills that can be used for the
measurement our last study is looking at
market rate associations for softness we
established to the trail to use last
year in October at 2000 Uganda using
augmented block design and we used a
diverse panel of 430 accession in this
picture arm this is a to destroy at one
of the site and we'll be harvesting the
trial in October this year and you will
see no tape the loop samples for
softness using the protocol which we are
going to devote in study to
and then after that we'll perform a
genome-wide Association study to
identify markers across the genome that
are associated with genetic variation
for softness earlier on I said that we
also collected the cassava leaf samples
from the farmer's field during the
service
we have genotype 2 this one's and using
GBS and here I'm showing them the tips a
plot for the for the genotype data and
the different colors represent the four
districts where we collected the samples
and one thing to note is much as they
are some related genotypes grown across
all retinas across all the districts
there are some genotypes that are only
grown in some locations and this could
explain some of the differences that we
observed across the that some of the
differences in quality preferences
across the districts and the genetic
diversity of the formals materials could
also be exploited by the breeders to
improve cassava for the quality
sequences of smaller farmers so in
summary we have been able to identify
the trade preferences that are important
to smallholder farmers and we are
currently optimizing protocols that we
can use to measure some of the
identified traits and we'll be doing the
genetic studies to help us understand
the genetic architecture for the
identified traits and all this
information will be useful to the
breeders in designing appropriate
reading strategies for the preferred
tricks
we start I would like to acknowledge
support from my advisers are the role of
members on the team at national cope
resources Research Institute in Uganda
where my food trails are located the
next gen cassava team and funding from
IIT and Gates Foundation
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu